in this segment we discussed splitting a
Poisson process into two different
streams so we have a Poisson process
with some arrival rate lambda and
whenever there is an arrival we decide
to send it either to one or another
stream and for example this arrival
might be sent to that stream this
arrival might be sent to this stream
this arrival might be sent to this dream
that arrival might be sent to that
stream how do we decide where to send
these arrivals we make those decisions
using independent coin flips of a coin
that has a certain fixed bias equal to
two so when this arrival comes there is
probability Q that it will be sent that
direction or probability 1 minus Q that
it will be sent in the other direction
all of these coin flips are independent
so the decision on where to send the
second arrival is going to be
independent from the decision of where
to send the first arrival and
furthermore we make one more assumption
that these coin flips are independent
from everything else they're independent
from the time history of the original
Poisson process for example the coin
flip that decides the destination of
this first arrival cannot depend on how
long it took for this arrival to occur
we will argue now that this stream is a
Poisson process and by symmetry
therefore this stream is also a Poisson
process we need to verify two
assumptions one has to do with
independence the argument here is
entirely analogous to arguments that we
have already carried out in the past
namely disjoint time intervals in the
original process our independent coin
flips that happened during those
disjoint time intervals are also
independent of each other and for this
reason whatever happens during this
joint time intervals in that stream will
also be independent the other property
that we need to verify has to do with
probabilities of small intervals if we
take a little interval here of
length Delta what is going to happen
during that interval well we look at
what happens during the corresponding
interval in the original stream in the
original stream the probability of
having two or more arrivals this
probability is order of delta squared so
there's no way of having two or more
arrivals during that little interval or
to be more precise the probability of
two or more arrivals here is going to be
negligible order of delta squared what
is the probability of having one arrival
during that little interval we will have
one arrival here if we've had one
arrival in this time interval which
happens with probability lambda times
Delta and also the coin flip
sent the arrival in this direction which
is something that happens with
probability Q and the remaining
probability is assigned to the event of
having zero arrivals during that
interval so the probability of two or
more arrivals is negligible and the
probability of one arrival is
proportional to Delta and that's what we
need in order to have a Poisson process
the factor of proportionality that
multiplies Delta is equal to lambda
times Q therefore this is a Poisson
process with parameter or arrival rate
equal to lambda times Q and by a similar
argument this process here is going to
be a Poisson process with parameter
equal to lambda times 1 minus Q so by
splitting a Poisson process using
independent coin flips we obtain two
different Poisson streams are these
Poisson streams independent for the case
of the Bernoulli process we had seen
that the resulting streams were not
independent the reason for the Bernoulli
process was that if I tell you that at a
certain slot we had an arrival in this
stream that would tell you that in the
corresponding time slot of the other
process you could not have an arrival
and that was a source of dependence it
turns out
for the Poisson process because it runs
in continuous time telling you that we
had an arrival at this particular time
instant does not give you any
substantial or any non-trivial
information about the other process and
the two processes remain independent
this result is surprising in some ways
but it is true a mathematical derivation
proceeds a long line that's a little
different from the intuitive argument
that I just outlined and we will not go
through that derivation but it's a
useful fact to know